One of my favorite parts about my job at the Gates Foundation is that I get to travel to the developing world...
...and I do that quite regularly.
And when I meet the mothers in so many of these remote places,...
...I'm really struck by the things that we have in common.
They want what we want for our children,...
...and that is for their children to grow up successful,...
...to be healthy and have a successful life.
But I also see lots of poverty...
...and it's quite jarring,...
...both in the scale and the scope of it.
My first trip in India, I was in a person's home where they had dirt floors,...
...no running water, no electricity, and that's really what I see all over the world.
So in short, I'm startled by all the things that they don't have.
But I am surprised by one thing that they do have: Coca-Cola.
Coke is everywhere.
In fact, when I travel to the developing world, Coke feels ubiquitous.
And so, when I come back from these trips, and I'm thinking about development,...
...and I'm flying home and I'm thinking,...
"Well, we're trying to deliver condoms to people, or vaccinations".
You know, Coke's success kinda stops and makes you wonder,...
..."How is it that they can get Coke to these far-flung places?"
And if they can do that, why can't governments and NGOs do the same thing?
And I'm not the first person to ask this question.
But I think as a community, we still have a lot to learn.